hello and welcome to this video Mike and
Ramos smoke Poland I've a rustle lemo
okay he's six Bishop d7 is one of the
main lines him for black slightly
slightly less popular then the other
continuations he doesn't really it
doesn't seem to be a fan of developing
all that much okay I'm going to take but
maybe I can punish him with Bishop c4 a
little bit more I mean black black is
playing in a very slow way development
wise and taking Andy for his very very
energetic
so okay as I hoped he did not really
look at f7 or what this is what how are
you how are you not getting your butt
kicked now Bishop c4 was kind of obvious
the idea I felt
never call you one it's the thing okay
so night of seven is going to win the
game you say anything better maybe even
mmm
probably not probably not Queen f3
with hindsight I wonder if I should have
done that actually in this way because
um okay I don't have to trade Queens I
can win another pawn on c6 or take huh
it's tough to say it kind of but if I
take this I don't like that too much
this is maybe stronger King us to take
and now continue with Queens on the
board and ds3 92 94 yeah that looks good
Queen a five applicants eform yeah
that's good
what you put it in 94
oh yeah it's actually debatable because
it looks nice only for for sure but it
isn't a check much you could have
thought about Knight f3 and that also
looked very viable now is nice but it's
not like I'm winning immediately okay
yet the knight should be on c4 now the
tacky 5 Queen to you form so he's
attacking the pawn
huh isn't isn't even so easier porn is a
little bit weak hmm yeah Quincy 594 23
2016 6 6 95 check I will be a pawn up in
an ending but that is really not enough
if you look at them you look at this um
okay I should absolutely not lose on
time but that's something that I should
not do
okay I'm returning the porn for the sake
of some quick moves the ending is
excellent of course but shouldn't death
spend so much time
king of one Guinea to roopd one I need
to get Dukes of the board night on c4 is
eternal the Bishop only three is covered
and the minor peace ending I'm winning
isn't him
even with equal material his pawn
structures too bad
is stuck to be 65 g5 and so on
okay so I'd have to be a little be
precise I care that he had to play him
let's see how do you tell you win it
actually do I have to go before or not
so that the bishop is actually attacking
this I had stuff to say and really
okay let's do it
keep him
I could get it over to you for now
g4 and then he has to give me a pawn
quite a now King me five all allow that
want one of those
hmm goddamnit
dude did I do Thomas play this stuff I
did miss play it I don't give me that
and it's still winning but I was scary I
was a little bit scary
mm-hm I'm not happy then the pollution
was so winning after the eight moves or
something that that that shouldn't
really happen he had some some odd scary
moment yeah probably
this is just stronger it's just a
stronger way of playing the Queen move
is was was bad now he asked to go we
should be six and we have the same thing
just like now he doesn't have the move
Queen f6 and something like d4 is
probably strong just open everything and
playful maid you really have to check me
black him yeah this yeah here I don't
think that this is great and I felt
something like that maybe and he's got
ideas like this in some cases this is
not so clear
I have no development so this is better
and of course this is a clearly better
position but it seems I should have
played you for the whole time yeah I was
a bit too relaxed damn I should go d4
and checkmate him I was just so it's so
much so happy about them strategic
advantages but this is of course very
strong because of Bishop f4 really that
was so lame I mean this is a super
comfortable position but it is not
comparable to the two mating yeah
what
but it's not too clear advantage really
because of 93 okay that is that is true
where if I cannot I need this but he has
got he can even take only three okay so
that would have been a real spanner in
the works who would have done that okay
I'm better after Bishop there too but I
would not have played at problem I mean
it's it's clear that this is so bad due
to the pawn structure but this is not
that will take a while okay now I'm can
I'm heading towards the minor piece
ending and that is that should one too
many weaknesses here and I'm not sure
about played it in the best possible way
but I think it was a way to win you know
before I have to do it and now there are
too many weaknesses I put it put it here
and now I can switch over with King b3
that it's not winning really maybe it is
but can I can I win in a different way
somehow completely
I don't see a way to outmaneuver him so
that I just win a pawn or something I
don't see it can play bishop
the engine is basically suggest
suggesting to move back and forth I
don't think there is a deep idea behind
it I can also I can turn it up a little
bit and see they would get somewhere the
large depth and I'm also really am I
said not wait let's check b5 is the only
move they play Bishop THM only later
played b5 but ok b5 cake cake
when before and then it just goes back i
just goes back
that could be a draw I could be a
fortress that's possible that that I can
believe in the game I'm winning here
with King D five right
then King B 3 is a mistake instead to
win Dan
I don't know I don't really see how it
could be if I cannot switch over to e4
don't really see when he ambition 7 I
mean I can what does the end you do it
just switches back and forth I don't
think that can win
maybe maybe here this is an idea so that
after Bishop c7 which is forced I can go
here it doesn't win you know how I said
winning like here should be for Bishop
f6 and maybe this wins because I have
this idea g3 and therefore that is
possible so I have to get I have to get
onto this diagonal in a situation where
he has to defend with Bishop f6 so that
I have the g3 f4 idea aha so that that
makes sense that makes a lot of sense
and can I force that so I go here yes to
do it like that
Bishop has to move on that diagonal I go
here threatening Bishop e7 Bishop here
Bishop f6 doesn't work with ship c7 we
should eat 7 and I'm there now so
probably it wins due to this maneuver
now I have G 3 F 4 and it wins I mean I
couldn't really believe that it
shouldn't be winning that that it cannot
be it just to it so bad like this this
this must be when it's just too too bad
everything is on dark squares him it's
impossible to believe that it shouldn't
be a win probably probably I can play it
better that that I can I'm happy to
believe the engine wants to play it with
this way it's interesting really see for
hmm this air it's not easier to say with
absolute certainty but that could be a
draw I don't think that this is great I
think I should play with before
simply because I need you I need be six
as a further weakness that I can
possibly attack and I need invasion
square so and I think I think the celina
that that I looked at has proven that it
should win okay guys thanks for watching